hi I'm Elizabeth Olsen and this is my
wired auto-complete interview okay so
[Music]
where is Elizabeth Olsen God from that's
a lot nicer than where's Elizabeth Olsen
Los Angeles where did Elizabeth Olsen go
to college NYU and I graduated five and
a half years
why was Elizabeth Olsen and Edinborough
because I was filming Avengers there
okay when was Elizabeth Olsen born
February 16 1989 when did Elizabeth
Olsen start acting that's a bigger
question because I think my first
professional job was when I was really
young but I didn't really start acting
then I don't think I would say my
sophomore year of college when I started
understudying how did Elizabeth Olsen
Timothy Xiao Mei meet I just bought a
Shalem a and Netflix t-shirt because I'm
a big fan of his and I don't know him I
took a picture with him at the indie
Spirit Awards he's a little dream of a
human how tall is Elizabeth Olsen in
foot how tall is impulsive in foot I
know what they were trying to say but
how tall those are the bolsa man feet I
am 5 feet and I don't really know how
many inches
some people say 5 some people safe sex
but I think 6 is generous how many
siblings is elizabeth Olsen have
technically I have three full siblings
and two half siblings but they're all
siblings you know they're all like
wholehearted my blood siblings how old
Elizabeth Olsen I am 29 that's how old I
am
how is Elizabeth Olsen I'm great thanks
for asking Google
is Elizabeth Olsen Scarlet Witch that's
more of a meta question I guess it's
Elizabeth Olsen in Avengers 4 is
elizabeth Olsen left-handed no but thank
you for thinking I'm one of those gifted
more creative people is elizabeth Olsen
Swedish no but again thank you again is
elizabeth Olsen age I do age in fact
I can move all of the muscles in my face
does Elizabeth Olsen dance yes
there's elizabeth Olsen have a drain yet
does Elizabeth Olsen have an accent I
guess it depends on where you're from I
think if we all have accents I think
that's what happens when people live in
different parts of the world we all
sound different not lovely
there's elizabeth Olsen have Twitter
nope there's a Lizabeth Olsen sing and I
saw the light I do it's my beautiful
shrill voice you get to hear in that
movie but yeah well I'm definitely not
finding for you uh-huh
what a blank super-heroes those with
Olsen Scarlet Witch but I just figured
out we never say Scarlet Witch I don't
think in the franchise so I guess I'm
Wanda what happened to Elizabeth Olsen's
accent I'll never tell what does
Elizabeth Olsen play in Harmon quest
can't remember but that was fun it's a
fun game but I'm amazed that that's even
on this list like how many people
actually watch Harmon class what college
elizabeth Olsen go to I think I answered
this NYU but I'm glad people are asking
in multiple different forms
what does Elizabeth Olsen do do I do I
like to I cook I work I don't make
people laugh her living this has been my
wired autocomplete interview thank you
for watching